in pipe or three two one hi everybody
this is a monkey today we are gonna cook
it's a soondubu jjigae is my pick it's
my favorite each is a little spicy he's
a little hot and sometimes to have a
little green I guess you know my
favorite recipe ingredient is Sami oil
Oh as a garlic
oh no sesame oil oh it's a sesame oh
yeah he's a big accordion so we are
imitating one of her recipes that I've
tried this lady named monkey you'll see
her on YouTube yeah she's uh she's
probably one of the first people to ever
do like legit Korean recipes her recipes
are a good foundation for you to start
your recipe and then you build it build
on it later and it's really easy to make
because when I was in Taiwan I used to I
was craving for Korean food and I mean
props to Taiwan for trying but they
could not make good Korean food so I
used to her among her recipe on YouTube
try to make legit Korean food I love the
way that she speaks hi everybody
booty body it's me monkey speaking of
Korean people apparently there was a
huge rumor that Kim jong-un died which I
didn't know well it's a rumor yeah South
Koreans think they're he's still alive
what well I think they confirmed that he
still is it's just like he was I think
he missed out on his grandfather's like
birthday or something and then he
wouldn't I guess I'll be really sick
he's enough maybe he has colvett or
something who knows but he well with
that body anything could happen
really yeah and like Kim jong-un
disappeared and I just thought it was so
funny cuz I got really upset when Kim
jong-il died because I had that
character Kim jong-il uh ruined my
character stupid [ __ ] like you got
upset oh so sad dude shoutouts to Kim
jong-il man that original homie you
created one of my favorite characters
Kim Jong era hi my name is a Kim Jong
you're not using them anymore well I can
but it kind of it kind of doesn't make
sense because the character was based
off of him it was basically Kim jong-il
goes to America to be the best that he's
so delusional
he's the
number one and everything's I'm a number
one rapper is that number one dancer
number one ship number one everything
but it's really just because he's this
all-powerful North Korean guy that kills
anybody who says otherwise is that one
of the sketches we the first one that
you did was Kim jong-un number one
husband and this one was like a funny
twist because this is bright when Kim
jong-il died and so when Kim jong-il
died I was like yo I can't use his
character but I can if I say that he
faked his death and he moved to America
so and that was like a real funny fun
sketch for me because I wanted to show
people that he has a weakness which is
his wife so his wife is way tougher than
he is right and the whole schedule yeah
and I'm trying to like kill her the
whole time but I can't do it and so I
try to fake my death as you know she
shoots me and stuff yeah so Kim jong-il
was is it's like he originally started
off as somebody that was supposed to be
somebody like Kim Jong Il but then I
just made the character into Kim jong-il
that thinks he's the best at everything
is mr. Illig and I come back I want him
to I actually have so what people don't
know is I actually shot a pilot for it
um with my riding buddy Deepak and we
I'm actually having it edited this week
oh yeah I'm gonna release it for people
to see it's a pilot episode on YouTube
yet Who am I the more happen North Korea
Kim Jong Il we only shot one pilot yeah
how long is it well I should be like
15-20 minutes yeah yeah Jeb my would you
have dated me if my boy sounded like
that hi my name is David and I was just
wondering sir if you know like if you
singer I'm single I mean who knows I
didn't I mean I was an attractive time
we're gonna recreate this that's all
that how dare you that is a lie what did
you just say that wasn't attracted to
you were lawfully human attracted to me
either Kim Jong Il uh sketch was the
first that's because I was in character
I was too busy working there Ellen was
married dude okay I'm a method actor all
right and then the second one second
time we met I was your girlfriend your
mom and your wife now I
you were attracted to me I was attracted
to you because you were funny were you
you weren't attracted to me at all when
you first met me not even a little bit
like oh this guy's kind of fun cuz you
know the first impression I had right so
my pet peeve or one of the things that
turns me off the most is a guy wearing
basketball shorts socks and slippers and
not even just a regular slippers if
their tongue slippers oh my gosh that's
like and then you're like dude this is
the first guy that I saw that I was
attracted to that's wearing everything
that I hate absolutely not and then you
know the first thing you said to me what
we shook our hands and you said oh you
remind me of someone that's right you
did look like somebody to me oh I know
it looked like I met you before but I
think it was somebody that fell in love
with in the future okay anyway I
remember I was like joking around with
you too when I first met you and then we
were we're flirting and stuff I didn't
know that was flirty I thought you were
just funny no you know I was G chili the
whole everybody in there I was flirting
- I was mad floored even Julia said like
you were super flirting with that
because Julia knows you I don't know you
because they've and the thing is I know
them actually have ever seen me like
flirt with somebody before but you're a
comedian so I figure oh this is his
personality there's other girls on the
set I'll just pop my eyes while you boot
and also I was doing a favor so I
figured that you were just being extra
nice to me I was like oh this guy is
very nice good Oh how's it no and then
and then at the end of the sketch right
before we went to go have dinner with
everyone we were in the room and then I
don't know where we were talking about
we were talking about something and then
my hand went to your hand and you held
my hand for a really long time looking
at me very with a very like greasy look
yeah I was like okay Gracie what do you
mean crazy yeah no no no I look buttery
I it was more like oh what's that yeah I
was like I'm gonna I'm gonna get any
trouble I'm heading out but you liked it
you still came up after let me tell you
something she tried to pull a Cinderella
on me and she left she left her she left
everything you know she left everything
at my house so every time she came over
to help me out with something right I
actually
the the second time she came over to my
place though I did find her attractive
it wasn't actually to hit on her I
needed her help to translate this script
for me because I wanted to write this
script in Korean because I was gonna do
this Korean short I actually had the
very first episode where I shot came out
[ __ ] terrible by the way and I wasted
like ten thousand dollars on it but she
was actually the one that I needed help
to help translate it so she translated
my English script into Korean for me and
so that's the second time that you came
over but every time she came over she
kept leaving things at my place so we
could meet up again it was only one time
it was a watching then you left some
other stuff to life I can't remember
what it was like hair clips or some [ __ ]
but it was after we started seeing each
other awful you kept leaving stuff man
you would like that person leaving
crumbs in the forest trying to get me to
come find you after those crumbs I found
those crimes I found those crumbs all
over the place I've built a sandwich so
you got tricked into my plan that's
right so you did like me what you say
like my love puppy here he's a little
treat yeah I'll see you next week
she was so funny when I she left this
Cartier watch that she got right was she
lost by the way there's you know where
it's at anymore the Cartier watch the
first time first time in Accardi away it
was the Cartier watch it was Jacob's no
no was later also you left multiple
watches it I didn't leave it at your
place I lost it at the beach when I
wanted I thought the first one wasn't a
Marc Jacobs it was a Cartier watch
really because that mario's rose gold
exactly Carter wasn't rose gold oh yeah
maybe you right thing
ahaha so I'm the one who left it there
alright okay my bad my bad I should know
about your diabolical plan so she not
leaving Kardashian lacy has to be a
little test
she left her mark Jacob watch and I was
like whose watch is this and it turned
out to be hers and so I used that
watched to just meet up with her again
at my friend Sofia she opened up the
Shabbo restaurant and then imma bided
her and my buddy had to come why is it
that I went with Ed then if you invited
me
I thought ed invited me I don't know who
we invited you but you were there and
then we kind of got the the watch watch
and I was like oh well we're gonna meet
up again you know you know what's so
funny about that thing what is that
because ed is the one who
picked me up I was friends with it the
whole time I was just partnering with it
you were sitting next to me I wasn't out
sandwich with Edie and David and because
I think all the people were on the left
side I kind of pushed my face my body
towards everyone else so my back was
facing what are you I remember that but
the point of that one was though that we
were there to celebrate my friend's
restaurant opening so yeah that was the
main thing and then you were gonna be
there so we had the I had to watch and
then I thought hey let's meet up after
though haha
and it's a queue and then after that she
hit me up out of nowhere
mmm and she was like so when are we
gonna hang out I was like oh no no no
honey was it you left you left a big
missing part of that story is that
afterwards you sent me a chunk like a
big message saying hey I'm interested in
you and I think it'd be cool that we go
out that wasn't a big thing was it
actually that you said that you said
that you're interested in me and it
would be great if we could go out and
like get to know each other and I don't
think I said I was okay we maybe then
yeah you did straight forward David so
you know I'm saying now cuz I had to
read them multiple times thinking what
is he saying what is he saying is this a
friend am i I'm even more
straightforward than I thought that's
pretty fast dude yeah you were that's
why I was so confused cuz we weren't
friends
we just meant like a couple times and I
didn't know if you're saying like let's
meet up as friends or more and I was so
confused Tim I don't remember saying
that for some reason I remember just
saying like hey let's meet up no she
said hey I think you're really funny and
cute and I think we should go up Davis
Davis oh man I'm proud of you dude yeah
yeah yeah 26 year old David self okay
you got balls I was like and you know
what somebody I was just like what the
heck is this and I started crackling
because I was like this guy thinks he
could just get any guys that's what I
thought yeah I remember this huh any guy
yeah any girl any guys - yeah you man if
I was gay I could get that dick - [ __ ]
gross so I you know what do you remember
what I said no I replied in Korean I
said Pato
Oh we'll see yeah but he took it as oh
yeah yeah we'll see like I'll get back
to you but for me I'm like um we'll see
up like two months later as if as if she
responded immediately she goes so when
are we gonna get that dinner and I'm
like you haven't talked to me in like a
couple months actually it was like three
weeks now it was like a couple of months
before you felt that way cuz you're so
hung up in there yeah I was like oh [ __ ]
you I do that every day you're looking
like you're foaming nah I'm looking I
was like I'm done dude I gotta do some
other people yeah I'm saying and as soon
as he felt that way I text him as I hey
let's go have dinner yeah and then lo
and behold look what happened to him I
didn't know I said that all in that text
that's crazy
you were straight for you're like we're
not being friends we're David I remember
that part but that was after we had
dinner and then but I didn't remember
saying that in a text though that's easy
I wish I wish I saved Alice it's good
Cal doesn't save all this [ __ ] well that
was before cacao oh was it
we didn't I mean we well we did that
after yeah but yeah and also cook call
doesn't save it that's why I said let's
just go back to iMessage you know when
we both had um I don't
yeah because at least that gets saved
yeah I wonder why cacao doesn't save her
they'll be so great she and I used to
speak so much through cacao all the time
like you like I wish we had those
conversations still so like a look back
on it because we you know we joked
around that we fought a lot on it so I
want to see like the stuff that we said
I know because she couldn't really speak
well in person when we would argue
that's at the time so now but so she
would rather wait on it and then write a
whole long diatribe for me to read
because her what she wanted to say was
more collected in the in writing verses
say to me at on the spot yeah I think
it's more or less I it came to me after
the fact like I needed some time to
think about it because at that moment it
was just like a blur but then when I
came back like home whatever and think
about it for a few hours it just
automatically comes in I'm like okay now
I got a like a let him know yeah yeah
what an interesting time the younger
version of ourselves I know I can never
20 I can never go back in time and do
that all over again I would I would die
what do you mean it was so stressful
getting to know you
why are the stress you were a closed
book what do you you would not oh you
don't you dare don't
you dare on this podcast she was careful
careful my ass she was such a closed
book hey I'm hard again I'm not an easy
girl I'm talking about even what we were
together like we got together as you
just cuz we got together saying I'm
gonna be like hey I'm all yours not like
that but then you just wouldn't open up
about anything you're so secretive about
everything you're live it was so
difficult I can't go through that again
everything was like I'll tell I'll tell
you when the time comes your favorite
thing like I would ask something you
like I'll tell you later
no Jack you go magic it lets you I don't
know like what just like small stuff
like whether it was about your like
relationship with your parents family or
something like those are the things that
you ask somebody in the beginning so you
get to know who they are and their
family you would never tell me any of
that stuff and I was like this is gonna
is she we doing here Mel we a couple or
not like I want to get to know this
person no our first night I remember
that we were talking about our family
high money mm-hmm but not your mom not
your dad not any of that of the stuff
well just your high money what is still
part of my family so yeah but then I
would i stuff about your relationship
with your mom and dad you never
mentioned you would never talk about any
stuff spill the beans all in one I don't
think that's spilling the beans Bonilla
was somebody somebody's trying to get to
know you like I don't want to dish it's
pretty I mean that's pretty sensitive
site I feel like it's just like you know
the part where like I don't want anyone
to know about it I anyone I was with you
yeah but we were we also got together
really fast and so we didn't really know
each other that's why you're asking did
you just say we got together fast right
now I will choke you out right now Oh
joke you out well I'm saying that we
didn't know each other like we weren't
friends first so it's not like you knew
a lot of stuff about me but I have
that's how I get to know you by asking
these questions and you letting me know
no no did you want to know earlier of
course I could get two we could have
sped up our process and we put publicly
got a lot every still wouldn't have
proposed to me too like okay I was gonna
propose to you earlier but you said no
yeah that well yeah because we don't
know each other that's why should say
something if I proposed to you was a no
so you wouldn't have the money for that
because you were invest
at that time amen I would have let go
one of my investments you went just to
give you a ring just to make you mine Oh
somebody cueing that horse right now on
a beach will be just but make it right
again
that's family guy back what's up main
guy's name I shut my Peter Griffin yeah
you just call me Peter Griffin that's
like that there's that one video someone
made mm-hmm
that was pretty [ __ ] hilarious that
was that was a good one
you know one of the the Twitter
subscribers asked us about Twitter
subscribers what the [ __ ] did I just say
patreon subscribers they asked about the
the first time we ever said like I love
you
and like how did that come about I was
actually the first one to say I love you
said actually the first phrase you said
was I think I'm falling in love with you
smooth David so I squeal I squeal I did
I remember that I would remember saying
that to you I think I'm falling in love
with you mm-hmm and I did feel it I felt
it I felt it through the marrow of my
bones and I came around like tabs in the
first few months yeah it was it's like
in the first life maybe four months or
something like that I thought to myself
like to kid okay I really fall in love
with me that fast do it you haven't been
doing nothing I'm just tired sit on had
on sit on your dad she wouldn't even
hold my hands at first like she just she
didn't she thought the concept of
holding hands was so stupid she didn't
she didn't get it she like I remember I
was like hey look hold my head I took
going for hand she goes why do people do
this is what she said she goes why do
people do that I don't get I don't get
why people hold I'm not really into
physical contact or I wasn't into
physical contact because I'm a sweaty
guy
I mean guy uh-huh I'm a sweaty dude to
begin with like my hands and my feet are
like the most sweaty part so it's
someone asked me to hold him like at her
feet are freaking hot dude do you think
they are either ice cold or hot as hell
she could literally make a panini
sandwich if she just sandwich her feet
together like that's not what you're
done son
she wouldn't she wouldn't hold my and I
remember the first time that we actually
held hands she really enjoyed it was
weird
and then she started to like it and I
forgot where I was either I went on a
show or I was gone for a certain period
of time and then she tells me she goes
you know what's so funny like I I I'm
miss holding your hands as I she was
with her best friend she asked her best
friend like I got accustomed to it like
it was what three years afterwards was
it yeah no it was it was way earlier
than that oh wait I got used to it like
oh that feels nice I see why like people
who are in a relation for a really long
time and they have a breakup that they
can't sleep by themselves now yeah cuz
you that wanted to hold hands all the
time and I wanted to touch someone all
the time if I like that person like I
don't know just grab onto them and if I
didn't hold her hand she'd get upset
yeah you trained me trained me to like
it so you all follow up okay guys so
upset that I wouldn't hold your hands is
because I my hands would get hot and
sweaty and why'd you ask me to hold your
hand because that day wasn't hot sweaty
it was hot it was hot but it wasn't
sweaty it was August hun yeah it was hot
we had I had AC the Jeep baby yeah but
you asked me to hold your hand when
we're walking yeah yeah those in the car
and then we held our hands in the car
too really yes I remember that's why I
was asking why people hold hands
oh and daash she's so she's such a phony
too the first time
let me tell you why she's such a phony
can't be there's like the most real girl
ever so there's there's this weird thing
and this is not just Muriel this is me
too this is everybody we all have a
perception of what we think we want in a
relationship what we think that we join
a relationship but you never really get
to understand what that is until you're
actually in a committed relationship and
that is something that I've learned you
know just being dating multiple times
and just kind of figuring or figuring
this as I went along because if I look
back to who I was when I was younger
right and I think about the first time I
ever had a girlfriend who I thought I
wanted to be with right that person that
I wanted to be with that first is not
the person who I am with now which is
you right do you want to be with was
your ideal I don't know if it would it
was like an ideal girl per se but I
think I
more girls who are the opposite of me
right a little more quiet a little more
pure it should not that you're a loud
farting girl and I just farted 24/7 I
don't know what you're feeding me but
it's not letting my stomach you know
this girl has been farting non-stop stop
feeding me where it stopped I'm feeding
you Korean food and I don't know she's
been farting this girl could create her
own Symphony if she wanted to taste you
farting so much
it's our language which is party yes hey
cuz you fart - oh yeah I know I fart but
what happened he was with like I don't
mind when girls fart like this that's
not an issue it's just I'm kind of
shocked at how much she's been farting
and how loud it's been there's been a
few earthquakes in LA it wasn't it was
it bitter Cleo just her far to get a
room
okay yeah but this girl like what Wells
going back to is that we have this
perception what we think we like and you
know case in point for Miriam when we
were first started going out she had a
few thoughts about what she thought she
enjoyed in a relationship well she
didn't like for example she thought she
didn't like hand-holding right and as
she found out there's this this is odd
connection that you have with somebody
with physical touch you start to miss it
you there's like a certain bonding that
you have like you see this in cases when
you know you know they did a case back
in the day where they found out that
children couldn't live well without
bonding to a human being they they would
pass away it was it was some kind of
crazy experiment also she was very very
adamant that she hated flowers she she
said specifically why do people give
flowers as gifts
it's going to die anyways it I still I
saw think like that okay then tell me
why did you roast me she here's the
thing okay I will tell you so I still
believe that flower giving far as a gift
is a waste because it does it just takes
up the space uh-huh it dies and you've
got to clean it up later and doesn't
smell good but what I didn't know is the
emotion that comes with when you receive
this beautiful bouquet of flower that
lives only temporarily and you're just
you feel you feel so special when you
receive
because that bouquet doesn't live
forever so you have to get a certain
time give it to that person a certain
time and it means something and I didn't
understand that until someone who I
loved gave it to me I've gotten before
from friends you know guy friends who
give it to me and I'm like oh this is
nice but what am I gonna do with it kind
of deal or like oh this is nice but like
I didn't feel that special emotion until
I got with you okay
she's trying to make herself sound all
nice right now and I'm gonna tell you
what it really is okay she did not feel
that emotion the first time I gave her
flowers the first time I gave that she
started feeling that emotion when she
was at work was the first time auntie
where she was that work right and it was
Valentine's Day and then all these other
girls were getting flowers she was like
flowers yeah one day we're chilling it's
Valentine's it mind you like mountains I
you know I take her out to eat and also
other stuff yeah then we're chillin and
then she goes you know it would be nice
if I got flowers for Valentine's Day and
eyes screeched look that I said what did
you just say to me she goes you know I
was at work and um you know my person
next to me got flowers and I was like
where's my flowers I hold on you legit
told me flowers are dumb that's why I
never got you flowers you told me you
didn't like flowers so the reason why
you waterfalls because you felt left out
no okay here's the thing
I've seen that before at other places
too
but I wasn't with a guy that I was in
love with so seeing that I'm like I
didn't I didn't care and I'm like oh I
have someone that I love too I wish I
could get that but prior to that I
didn't care I'd be like oh good thing I
didn't get one you said hasit me about
who set me up for failure I was shocked
but I didn't get mad at your anything I
just said hey it would be nice if I you
were you weren't upset but it was more
like you were kind of like hurt yeah how
could you get how could you be hurt
about something that you set up for me
you told me not to get you flower
and then I told you moving for giving
ours and this year I didn't get anything
but it's fine what are you talking about
what did you get though I don't know
what did I get
we got a lot of great things together
where do we go huh
exactly dinner exactly well okay it's
okay it's not the dinner it's the
flowers I get out on this podcast you've
never allowed on this podcast get your
flowers huh no okay I'm a grown flowers
how about that that means every
Valentine's Day you'll have a bouquet
waiting for you oh speaking of that so
this reminds me of something when I did
in high school I thought it was the most
romantic thing that I've done to my mom
so a Mother's Day do you remember those
flowers where it was was it was like
hair sprayed or something so that it's
hard and it has like glitters and
different colors it's a flower
it's like bouquet of flowers maybe it's
an Asian thing or it's in our town where
like every formal dances we would get
this like really pretty flowers I was um
hairsprayed or something so that it
hardens and it it lasts for months
there's companies that do that where
they were they dip the Roses into like a
type of resin or some type of chemical
uh-huh and it makes the the Rose stay
that way for a long yeah for a really
long time and so I got a really nice
bouquet of flower and I put a fake one
in the center mm-hmm and I gave it to my
mom for my Mother's Day and I wrote a
letter to her I was like I will love you
until all of these flowers die and then
put parentheses one is fake and inside
she looked at it and she was so obsessed
she's like how could you say this to me
I'm like mom what what are you talking
about and she's like you're gonna let me
only till this these florists live is
like so you're not gonna love me forever
and I'm like look this is one of the
flowers is faking the inside and she did
not see that she just complete got
blindsided by everything else and I said
that's so funny and she got so upset and
I remember that what did she say after
is she ready for that oh no she is she
just didn't listen to me she couldn't
hear anything she was actually mad at
you she was so upset I was like that's
the last time doing a surprise thing for
her why would she get upset though she
didn't understand
she literally didn't understand that I
put a fake fire inside but you wrote it
in there yeah and I even told her I was
like mom this is fake but I don't know I
don't know what happened afterwards mom
so funny dude she got so upset your mom
is so funny you know what's so funny my
friend told me so you know that crash
landing on you yeah it's a Korean drama
on Netflix you got such a high rating I
hated that drama with everything I love
that they just know was a scene and that
drama or they spelt out like a love
letter with every book in the bookshelf
what a [ __ ] dumbass does that see
that oh that's a thing that's like it's
on Netflix a lot of non-koreans watch
these right and when those kind of
scenes come out I'm wondering like do
they understand what we're watching here
cuz I'm squealing is saying I love you
it's the dumbest premise ever this girl
lands somehow it ends up in North Korea
and the she gets found by the one guy
that's not gonna shoot her to death
clearly this is a fictional story I know
but it gets so fictional I you just
believe it it's so it's too fictional
it's like really fictional that's why
you could believe in it if it's like
kind of real but fictional then you're
like what which world am I supposed to
be in but it's so fake that you just
believe it it's like you know cartoon
you know it's fake so you could believe
in it it's it's too fake though like
it's it's like I know because I mean I'm
not one to speak because I love hi bye
mama right which is a ridiculous premise
to however the story and the people and
the conversations are very very I
realize why you like that drama what
it's the way you talk to when you talk
about when you do your own vlogs or what
do you call those yeah blogs right yeah
you are funny but then you always have
this serious message at the end yeah and
that's what high Bhama is well hi bye
mama also just they speak like human
beings like that's how people talk you
know what I mean like when they joke
around or when they have serious
conversation you to to y'all you don't
know create ugh it's not like North
Koreans but it's just like the way they
talk is so it's just dumb like I've sat
there and I listen to you watch that
[ __ ] and I want the whole world is
against you now bring it [ __ ] I don't
give up food all right looking like it's
okay but
that story that I brought up is that
there is a mom there she's North Korean
rich mom and she knows how to speak
English and she reminds me of my mom oh
darling Oh what is going on and I looked
at my best friend and she's like he said
wrote to say that she reminds me of your
mom I don't like Muriel's Mama's fans he
did my mom is cutest I've never seen the
top of Muriel's mom's head ever in life
she's always wanting to have even at
night when we're at the house I was like
oh she still have a hat off even I
haven't seen it for the longest time I
don't even know if she has a top of a
head or not I'm assuming that there's a
hat there and then when she opens it up
it's just her own this is her brain like
what is going where every time I see her
I feel like she just popped out of a
cartoon
she's just so tiny Muriel's mom too is
just endowed with jewelry she said
you'll never see this woman's ready to
go all the time like you'll never see it
without makeup looking pristine as [ __ ]
my mom's different she's like the fanny
pack like the sauce shoes the the the
puffy vest and with like kimchi in her
hands kimchi cloves well Muriel first
came over to my place to Sacramento yes
she was gonna spend the night she my mom
has like these very just she has a very
warm vibe like it's very warm and
welcoming and if I bring somebody that I
care about to my household she she
invites him like open-hearted this woman
eats my mom's food and then she just
started bawling my mom's like who are
you crying she just starts crying as she
eats she's eating my mom's food and I
was like why is this woman crying and
then it's because it reminds her of her
grandmother which is her food yeah my
mom has very good homey food like no
matter how I make my Korean food it
never tastes like my mom's I don't know
why they remind me of cheap Bob because
ever since my grandma passed away we
didn't really have cheap Bob cheap of is
what like just like my homemade how
Korean food I need get the liquid out of
my face um oh my god
yeah so we haven't had cheap buff for a
while and usually like my aunts come
over and then then we would have Korean
food but then if they're not there then
usually we just have other types of
cuisine which is fine but it's just it's
been a while maybe about a year year or
so right over a year since I've had my
grandma's food so when I went to David's
house it felt like I went back in time
and have my grandma's food known all
these emotions were just like building
up and on top of that David's mom
reminds me of my aunts because of her
vibe and the way she talks and the way
she looks
I was like whoa this is kind of weird
and so I got it really emotional my mom
is a very very fun person to be around
to like I feel like one of the biggest
reasons why I wanted to be with somebody
who spoke Korean and I know this is a
very it's kind of a weird concept for
people where I feel like no you're fine
I feel like it's a weird concept for
people when they think about when they
say like oh when you're I truly believe
that when you end up with somebody right
you should be thinking about the
relationship that you'll have with this
person for the rest of your life right I
mean sometimes because family ties are
so strong a lot of people they based who
their partner is going to be based on if
mommy and daddy are gonna like them but
my mom has always said something else
where she goes like I would love it for
there for you to date somebody who's
Korean or can speak Korean because I
want a relationship with my with my
granddaughter or with my daughter-in-law
right which is a great thing to think
about but my mom also said to she goes
at the end of the day though like when I
pass away you're gonna be left with your
choices and you're gonna be left with
the person that you're with the the
mother of your child so just you know be
with somebody who's good to you even if
they can't speak Korean but I would
prefer that but for me it is very
important that I got was somebody who
could speak Korea which did it become
important to me until later in life
because I didn't realize how how Korean
I am right I'm super super shocked how
Korean you were yeah the more I got to
know you though I'm like did you live in
Korea cuz I lived in Korea and you feel
like I feel I feel the connection yeah
like I um
I'm very I'm very culturally Korean like
I'm a girl watching a lot of Korean
stuff I mean I grew up watching a lot of
Korean stuff my my mom doesn't speak
English so I have to speak later like my
Korean isn't the best but the fact that
you could say money if you what is it
know the numbers yeah like County two
different because Koreans we have two
different way of counting numbers one is
currency one is for something else and
you know the difference yeah like my
Korean it's funny because like some
people listen to my your Korean is not
that great and it's funny the people who
say my Korean isn't great they're crazy
ten times worse than mine it's like shut
the [ __ ] up like I it's it's weird like
Korean people are so odd about language
like when they criticize other Korean
people speaking of Koreans so harshly I
don't know why [ __ ] Korean people do
that like Korean people Koreans as in
Koreans who notice be Korean or discreet
who don't either they know or don't know
they go oh you're cranes not that great
it's like what the [ __ ] you're Koreans
worse than mine dear that's interesting
I usually get the opposite if I'd speak
Korean not that or you know speak a
language usually I get positive feedback
like oh you're actually better than I
thought yeah it's just such a ha I don't
know why but I feel like Korean people
scrutinize each other a little too harsh
about like language [ __ ] so much like
even if I was in let's say I went to
Korea right and I couldn't speak Korean
very well oh I feel like that I think
they might if you look Korean and you
can't speak well they might think you're
a little bit weird I've had that kind of
experience
well that's I'm saying it's like if I
tell you that I'm from America looks
like it's like the drama that we're
watching right now live up to your name
on Netflix yeah so there's this guy and
the character a long story short is that
he comes from Joseon era which is like
400 years ago and he comes to present
area and they people try to talk to him
but he doesn't understand all these
terms that they're using cuz it's so
current I've had and then they look at
him I was like kinda crazy guy and I had
that experience when I wasn't living in
Korea because there were certain terms
that they use so I was in the bus and I
was like I was asking the driver bus
driver I was like hey how do you get to
this place and he's like oh just go
straight down and in and you know on the
intersection and make a right or
something but I didn't know how to I
don't under I didn't know how to say in
an intersection and make a right how do
you say intersection I don't know
I still don't know he's like corn Mook
no that's Ali I don't know yeah but I
forget tamp anyway so when he said that
to me I was like Oh what how do you say
I know I asked him was like what is it
intersection and he looked at me he's
like what the hell like he gave me that
look and I was just and then no joke I
added English accent right after that I
was like um Oh yogi yogi old ticket guy
oh yeah and then he's like oh and he
gave me the another look he's like oh
maybe you're not Korean after all he's
like I'll just get out and I just go
straight you know but I feel so
humiliated uh at that time I was like oh
my god someone just actually looked at
me as if I was stupid that's so
interesting that I'm saying like that's
right there's a lot of times I have to
use that all right it did I don't have
to try that's already there it's already
man yeah but I for me I wanted to be
native there like I want to make sure
that I could communicate in that I mean
you just got that right I guess I
remember yeah yeah but the speaking the
language part is super important like
just to go back to what I was saying
because you know my mom she can't speak
English like she can she knows how to
get a get around at the store and that's
about it and so the only way that you
would have ever developed a relation
with my mom is if you spoke Korean best
I didn't speak Korean how do you think
we would still be together
we would still probably would still be
together but you it would be very hard
for you to be around my family though
because my mom is so Korean but like
even for you right now
like we had a conversation not too long
ago so my mom is not my parents aren't
people who open up to other people that
well they don't have a crap ton of
friends
they have a very select they're just
like me I have a select amount of
friends and there's a lot of
acquaintances right and that's why I
mean how many times do you see people
even prior to COBIT how many people came
to our house not much right I shouldn't
well I'm saying like but you know like
if you have a lot of friends like your
friends will come over and kick it but
not a lot of we don't invite people like
that over right and the only people that
you have but you already know like
weren't jo you know that that's really
about it
right other than that so you know for
you to my mom so my mom told her before
she goes hey like
now that you know my son is proposed to
or whatever you you guys are engaged
like you know I want to develop a
relationship with you so you know just
give me a call every now and then right
and I think for her it's for for Muriel
it's really hard because my family it's
we're very very well connected like we
talked on the phone a lot right which I
think typically for a lot of Korean
people that I know they'll do that
yeah well I I don't know but seeing the
relationship that you have with your mom
it's not something I'm used to know what
I'm saying like I'm thinking from other
friends too exactly I don't think I
don't know anybody who does that
all my Korean friends growing up I think
that they only talk to their parents for
hey how are you doing are you okay
how's things cool anything like yeah
having like a full-on conversation for
that long and that often isn't really
common yeah because usually it's a task
it's like more we're calling just to
check in because we have to like for me
I talked to my mom on the phone for like
an hour
yeah you know it's definitely different
yeah she likes talking on the phone and
so I like for me the reason why it's
important for you to know how to speak
Korean is because my mom the only way my
mom unless she moves here is to develop
a relationship with you is to speak to
you that's about it and you know people
can say otherwise right they go oh well
might you know I have a wife or a
husband who doesn't speak the language
and they get along getting along and
connecting are two different things
language is so [ __ ] important there's
new ones right even when when you watch
like films like Korean films right if
you don't understand the Korean language
even if it's translated you still don't
understand the nuance to why it's so
funny why it's this what people have
watched parasite right and there are
parts that are so funny to me it's not
funny to anybody else because they don't
understand the nuance in the language or
it's not as funny as what we think
exactly so there's there's nuance and
there's there's a connection that you
have when you could speak the Winkies
Korean language is so funny it is so you
know if you couldn't speak Korean yeah
it would have been a bigger issue but
you know like when my mom asked you to
call and then you know it was very
awkward for you to do it when I told her
too that my mom's feelings were getting
a little hurt right because she wanted
to connect to Muriel but I asked that I
have to do but I also had to tell my mom
I was like I'm like you can't you know
put that pressure on her because you
have to understand like the way that we
communicate isn't how everybody else
communications their children
so when you asked like muriel to you
know talk to you on the phone have
casual conversation if she doesn't do
that within her own family
how weird is it for her to do it with
her mother-in-law like that's something
that you have to be a little patient
with but you know the cool thing is like
this year muriel actually called my mom
like twice and then my mom's mood was
like oh she was like oh she's so happy
you have no idea how happy that made my
mom I mean that's good cuz it was a lot
of effort for me it was so just getting
to that call button oh I could imagine
it's it's not much physically it's not
much of work right it's just like click
click but the pressure and the
preparation to do that I don't know it
was just it was such a hard it was a
challenging thing for me and I'm glad
that she liked it because it was hard on
my own because that's not something I'm
custom I'm used to doing with my family
like our family we don't really do we're
not a phone person like prior to you
know being with you two I wasn't really
a phone person I hate talking on the
phone because then I like it's I get
distracted because I can't see that
person when I'm talking yeah yeah and
and our family too when we just meet up
then we talk but outside of that we have
our own life like my parents are very
social maybe that's the thing it's just
that and like your family my family is
very social like very out there has a
community that they hang out with and
they have their own separate community
so my mom has her own Fred's dad has her
own friends and his friends and then
they're just so busy having a life which
is great you know I'm just really happy
that they have a life very modern
relationship like that's like
relationships that people have been are
are charged my mom's very modern yeah
yeah so for the nine the 1800s Parisian
home that you guys have oh and the
requirement that she has for her job
their house looks like the Louvre in
Paris like there's like naked Cupid
wallpaper all over the place like where
did you get this Parisian couch I don't
even know how she sourced this furniture
it's like an old like in the old
Frenchman made all the harness it looks
like a cafe it's not a house it's a cafe
I walk in and I'm like who did you who
decided to sit here cuz I don't feel
like I should be sitting back I was like
what what old Parisian man did you kill
for this like who made this
what's all handcrafted she was meant to
be born in Europe oh for sure
what's so funny yeah and the way that we
live is very modern but the requirement
that she has for her child is very
traditional like she's like make sure
you don't have a boyfriend until after
college I'll pray for you that you don't
have one but let's go have blind dates
oh you should be more like this it's
like listen listen traditional like I
will like where it's my kid I will kill
you before you date somebody why aren't
you married yes like hold on a second
why'd you marry where is my
grandchildren it's like Oh it's like why
don't you marry where's my grandchildren
but don't you ever [ __ ] date anybody
ever yeah it's like well hold on
everything since my brother said the
funniest scene of my mom my mom was like
my mom was like I want grandchildren why
don't you marry my dad's my brothers
like you know you don't have to get
married to have kids like pop one in
right now my mom's like yeast that's the
thing so weird is that my parents are so
modern at the same time very traditional
but that said though our relationship is
very like moderates like you do your
thing and then you know he saw Shikibu
so cheeky he's so cheeky rockhole it's
what it means is that no update means no
bad news like how do you translate that
I've never heard that saying before so I
was hoping you could explain so
basically it means if there's no call
that means nothing's wrong okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you know that's how we
kind of live and so the fact that your
mom was asking me to call it's like what
do I talk about what do I say but the
fortunate part is that she loves talking
and she is so sweet like the way she
talks to you it makes you feel like
you're worth something and there's value
in life and like there's no pressure of
being like daughter-in-law is just like
hey you do you you live once go and
travel go and do this with your you know
with David like have a life you know
don't think about other people and I'm
just like what she's not talking about
expectations she
not talking about what you should do
what you have yeah my mom doesn't really
do that in a conversation I mean she
does that with me right but here and
there yeah yeah but it's it's funny cuz
my mom was like yeah now that you're old
like I'm not here telling you what to do
and I'm like yeah you do she goes yeah
you're right you're my son but you know
my mom's just there to really have fun
in conversation like my dad's not very
great at that and we had a conversation
why he's like that's cuz he's never had
that relationship with his parents so
which I understand but my mom she could
just talk about [ __ ] all day she
could and I'm so grateful that I grew up
with Korean culture in my life like a
lot of dramas a lot of shows you know
having my grandma around watched all
kinds of drama and I could talk to your
mom that's like a huge part where we
could talk to each other and like have a
cuz she watches a lot of drama she knows
what's going over there so like I could
be part of that conversation and she
gets super excited and when I talk about
old dramas like there's an old drama
about acupuncture her name hutchins yeah
and I brought that up maybe like the
second time I saw her and she's like oh
my god you watched that drama yeah oh
yeah you so watch that I still watch
like pull with the bull but it's like
really like early 90s drama and she got
super excited and you know every time I
see her she talks about celebrities to
me and I know what exactly what she's
all about because I grew up with them
well this is this is a great
conversation topic because I don't think
sometimes people understand when they
say you know family is important to me
right so I mean definitively what what
do you mean by family is important to
you like it's family important to you in
the sense of just the family that you
create with the person that you're with
are you talking about everybody that's
involved because sometimes when we think
about relationships when we get with
somebody you think that you're only with
that person but you're not the moment
you get with somebody you are also a
part of their family a part of their
friends and you become a part of this
web there whether they've spun and
they've created prior to the prior to
when you came in so being in a
relationship is a lot more than just
that single individual yeah I agree
after your parents pass away even my mom
told me that I have to stick with my
life choices and the people that I'm
with but while my parents are here
because family is important to me and
this you know whatever how many years
I've been alive 32 years I've been alive
that I have this relationship with my
mom it's also very important to me too
it's also important in like
when we have kids right how important is
it to me that my kids can be able to
communicate with had money and how to
write and they can't speak Korean and
then how many inaudible just comes in
and I see this all the time with kids
who don't know how to speak to language
with their grandparents it's just are
you hungry
yeah you want to play with toys yeah
that's it and it's so hard to watch
because they can't communicate with each
other why when my aunts met you the
first thing that they says you're Korean
you speak Korean they got so excited I
don't even think they cared that I could
that I was Korean as I could speak
Korean yeah I think that threw them off
yeah right it was more like and it
wasn't just and when people say they
speak Korean by the way like my Korean
isn't the best but I can have a
conversation like you you can understand
that hundred percent yeah it's just your
cuz you're you're used to listening but
you're just not used to speaking yeah
you could totally talk to them yeah I
could speak it just takes me a while to
warm up because I don't speak it as
market anymore if I'm talking to my mom
on the phone and then I talked to her
parents after then it's easier because
it's already there but what happens is
it's like because it's not in use I get
caught up in work I'm like I should know
this word like why don't I know how to
say this more yeah but when I talk to
her parents is super slow at first and
as we speak into speak throughout the
day it's ourselves coming back yeah and
then it starts to get easier so it's all
about practice but with that - like
would I be able to speak to your dad no
your dad isn't speak English right talk
to your mom your mom speaks perfect
English but then I wouldn't be able to
have a relationship with your father and
then I feel like the big approval
process that I have with your family was
because your aunt's like me so much also
because I look like one of their sons
yeah which is so interesting I know yeah
so like I don't know like I feel like
that language part is very important I
just don't want my culture to die I
think that's the thing I get scared
about the most is like I see people who
they kind of disregard the importance of
culture a lot like I'm not I don't feel
a certain way if people want to do that
right but I do appreciate when people
choose to instill a big part of who they
are into their into the generations
that's that's ahead of us so when you
had this kid and yet though we are here
in America I want our kids to be able to
speak Korean I wanted to like Korean
food and I want them to understand where
they can
for me why I am the way that I am and
who they are and why they look the way
they've been look it's because you are
Korean there's a huge part of who you
are that's in your blood that's I truly
believe that it's interesting cuz when I
was growing up I actually try to hide
the fact that I was Korean because I
couldn't blend with my Korean friends
whether that was Korean friends in Korea
or Korean American friends here like I
just couldn't connect because I was so
we have something called a second
generation rate for Koreans yeah there's
first generation which is are usually
our parents and then second drainages us
and there are some of us out there we
call ourselves 1.75 yeah I'm first
generation
you're first generation no you're second
your goal parents are first I wasn't
born here I was born in Korea for sure
all right I forgot I I got my
citizenship when I was like 23 I forgot
about yeah yeah yeah oh I'm I'm
technically second African English dude
but because I lived in Korea for a bit I
had a hard time figuring out who I
should blend with but I felt like none
of the Koreans accepted me for who I was
so I had a lot of resentment to Korean
so in my during my teens I pretended
that I was not Korean and people and
also I didn't look Korean I look people
a lot of people asked me if I was
Japanese I just kind of absorb that but
like yeah I guess I am hmm and kind of
stay away from this Korean culture
culture until later on in my life is
when I really appreciate it how much I I
grew up with Korean culture and just
being experienced living in that culture
because I mean it's so useful now you
know I could there's so many people out
there who are very interested and want
to learn and also you know I could
utilize it with my aunts who can't speak
English I could utilize it with your mom
you know not that only know how to speak
Korean but then I also understand the
culture so I could communicate you know
really using their language yeah I mean
this is important like I said previously
yeah because you speak Korean like
you're allowed to have a relationship
with my parents and our relationship
gets stronger too and once again I'm
just gonna reiterate this this is just
an opinion of mine you know if you if
you have a relation
you can't communicate with your in-laws
and you say that's fine that it's fine
for you but I do believe as a [ __ ]
fact just because I've I've had I've
never really been with a Korean girl
besides you and then the girl before me
before you that it just wasn't possible
you know there was the nod
there was the hi there was a smile but
because they couldn't speak to each
other my mom likes to talk she likes to
get to know people sure that's where the
relationship would have stopped she's a
very sweet girl that's it so that's one
of your core values that you want yeah
like what the court the huge over
looming you know core value is that
family's important right so like when we
get together I don't want that girl just
to be able to stay next to me and then
have me translate everything that's
going on oh my mom is asking that you're
hungry oh my mom's asking how is work
it's dumb because there will never be a
bond there if you're okay with that
you're you are but for me because I care
about the family strength a lot with
generations before and after like I need
that language part to be there because
my mom can't speak English and my dad
can't lose beginners right so when I ask
you let's speak Korean so we could
practice how come you don't do it
because body upper body Apple how did
you eat at the end about Samuel at the
body up oh okay we're gonna go into
Korean I bought it a sciatica nuka-cola
message in managua message it misses
yeah Ilan emoji could you down the where
yeah yeah kebab Rahab saw that ones and
perfect yet Nevada Nevada
yeah well guys that wraps up this
podcast but talked about the importance
of culture family rehashing how we first
met
right the importance that I'm Cinderella
Cinderella my ass the Taurus you there
thank you
he didn't get me flowers this year it's
okay no we talked about that later
anyways guys that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast we will yeah
this podcast is here just for regular
conversation talking about basic [ __ ]
see if you guys can relate to it I'm
just here to be along your day and to
fill those boring times in between pop
us up in the background of your daily
lives put us all on on your commute and
genius brain will be there for you guys
we will catch you all next time love you
so much kiss me on the face and punch me
in the butt bye bye
[Music]